censé être en live tu as quelqu'un qui
écrit dans le chat j'ai la flemme de
monter mon blog mais pas content il
montera pas son blog pierre alex guy
lafleur tapage thomann paco je peux même
pas comment te faut que le fomc a créé
un faux que tu créé un compte twitter ou
la wii bon tant pis preuve d'un plan ps
bon du coup aujourd'hui absolvent
normalement c'est le grand jour c'est
pour ça que lui si excitée phillies et
justement quand on s'est appelé la
guerre était hyper chaud parce que c'est
le premier choc alors wes laisse au
numéro deux mondial déjà ça allait je
guéris numéro 9 voilà donc le numéro
deux qui part à direct sépare direct sur
le numéro 9 et anis guiry je peux te
dire que d'après moi c'est un des trois
quatre joueurs potentiels qui peuvent
théoriquement devenir un jour champion
du monde
c'est juste qu'il est un peu en train de
changer son style il était numéro 5 6
mondial un moment donné il modifie un
peu son style il a perdu quelques places
mais il est très jeune et je pense que
guérif donc en fait les deux joueurs
sont potentiellement pour être champion
du monde un jour en fait ouais donc ces
deux grosses grosses stars en fait qui
s'affrontent dont l'un qui est donc
arrivé numéro deux il a complètement
explosé l'année dernière il a joué à un
moment donné je me rappelle plus
exactement le nom mais je crois qu'il a
joué 63 parties sans défaite d'affilée
consécutive donc c'est à lui cet accord
laisse pas un petit à petit rigolo non
blancs il a il a gagné les quatre gros
tournois consécutivement et de l'autre
côté donc guiry qui a eu sur un vin qui
était un peu sur la pente descendante
mais je pense qu'ils en train de revenir
en forme
donc c'est vraiment deux de deux top
joueurs là ce soir
aucun bon ben ça risque d'être cool par
contre s'il ya une si grande différence
j'espère qu'il serait quand même serré
un petit peu aux imams 2,9
ça va être serré t'inquiète pas 2,9 ça
va être serré la dernière fois on avait
regardé après j'avais pas le numéro mais
il n'y qu'à rouen nakamura c'était genre
numéro 9 au moment où regarder le match
et grigorian de sang face était numéro
552 tu vois voilà ces deux comptent neuf
c'est ça doit être serré normalement ok
mais c'est hyper excitant du coup bah
ouais on commence à 19h pile là
normalement normalement ils n'ont pas
trop de retard mais ils n'ont pas trop
de retard on va récupérer le chat rose
actuelle ighirri sera pas champion du
monde
trop peu de victoires on verra on verra
suivant ce qui change de style alors
j'ai partagé le lien comme excuse
absolue peut arrêter de manger près du
micro au bout tu te fais déjà défoncée
dès le début dès la première seconde
tu manges pas tu bois plus c'est fini
ces mères aujourd'hui
du coup jésus est un bon exemple d'un
double de cloyes je suis d'un sacrifice
doute
waouh ils sont philosophique les gens tu
peux manger tranquille en gt je rigolais
juste avec le chat un qui fait toujours
marrer ils t'empêche de tout faire en
fait le plus rien faire je peux même
plus commentés d'après certains ou
est-ce qu'il est le lien d'ailleurs je
le retrouve plus
alors je sais que cette chaise quand
même tiré vers le bas et cheikh lô que
reprendre celui-là donc hors petit pub
sur twitter ça va être ça va être
bouillant
c'est parti c'est parti c'est parti
c'est parti
comment ça se laisse même et on lit en
mettant les uns mais ton lien est en jeu
m'a plu je regarde pas embêté à la pub
fait ta pub et donc c'est parti c'est
donc le premier choc
ouais c'est soigné ni guéri donc pour le
monde et une sicilienne
alors là ça va ça va envoyer du lourd
intéressant que guérir ou la sicilienne
d'ailleurs il joue pas mal de nage des
enfants souvent malgré le fait qu'il
fasse beaucoup de nuls ils jouent des
parents très agressive et les gens se
trompent un peu sur ce joueur en pensant
que c'est un mec qui fait que des nuls
en fait paris fait que des nuls mais il
essaye de se battre à fond on en sait
plus qui réussit pas à faire à finir
c'est parti au québec on a une structure
de pions qui va ressembler un petit peu
à une flèche nikov ou une kalachnikov
avec le pion en d6 qui est arriérée ici
et donc s'il est noir réussissent à un
jour à pousser des saints qui réussiront
à éventuellement même prendre l'aventage
mais le cavalier viande et 5 pour les en
empêcher
je pensais toujours la théorie ici
j'essaie être crocs
tu me un compte et la gouache je me
petit peu mais j'arrive je te laisse je
vais gérer mais que tu es là je viens
vengeur masqué j'arrive du coup hockey
est intéressant et le changement cet
échange en d5 du coup les plombs ont été
obligés de reprendre 2e mais ça leur a
permis d'éviter des 5 mai structure de
pions du coup plus forcément vraiment
al'avantage des blancs les noirs
majorité allaient le roi les noirs que
les blancs majorité halal dame qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire comme plan ici il va
falloir activer les pièces avec les
noirs peut-être
8 f5 tous poussés h3 peut-être est-ce
qu'on peut jouer cash kader cavalia h
katia peut-être fou j'ai cinq du coût
qui attaquent le pion et qui cloue le le
cavale du puisqu'on faire un truc comme
cavalier h7 f5 f4 ou est ce qu on donne
trop de cases blanches qui ont fait ça
question que je me fais et je suis
actuellement en live de 19h à 22h pour
commenter deux parties d'échecs de 5,3
une minute vous a mis le lien sur
twitter et facebook
donc n'hésitez pas à dire bonjour à la
ta fait le taff et l'installent g josse
et snob ce match là bas j'ai pas encore
snapshot d'ailleurs je suis trop vieux
pour ça cet instrument il faut que j'aie
mal me leçon aux coquillages c'était g4
je suis un petit peu à l'étonné en fait
ouais c'est soit du goût qui prend les
devants et qui contre attaque
et qui contre attaque lui même ok t'es
instagram maintenant et je suis
actuellement en live de 19h à 22h pour
commenter des parties d'échecs de 5,3 et
une minute je vous ai mis le lien sur
twitter et ma page facebook donc
n'hésitez pas à venir me voir on va bien
s'amuser ensemble aller à tout de suite
sera le jour où jury sur instagram isna
chat
ce sera du très bon hockey les sabots je
suis loupé
théo fait alors donc du coup bon bah tu
as raté un truc mais qu'on reverra parce
que les débuts de partie à mon avis on
va aller voir et les revoir tu te
rappelles la dernière fois ils avaient
déjà souvent joué les mêmes ouverture du
mont choisy tombera même chose du coup
j'imagine que ça va être pareil
aujourd'hui et est ici donc en fait tu
vois il ya un gros conflit sur la
colonne h
tu vois cette colonne là ouais en fait
s'il est blanchi il réussissait à mettre
à mettre tout leur tour sur la colonne h
il pourrait gagner la partie mais les
noirs vont jamais laisser faire c'est
une sacré roi 3g c'est parce qu'il va
mettre lui aussi les tours sur la
colonnade donc les blancs peuvent pas
vraiment gagner ici donc à l'est le roi
c'est un espèce de gros combats de
l'autre côté allèles dame pour le moment
il se passe pas grand chose en fait
du coup ici tu vois il ya ces trois
pions là mais qui font plus ou moins
face à ces trois pions là donc on voit
pas vraiment comment progresser ici avec
les blancs pour le moment
en revanche ce qu'on peut voir c'est
qu'ici tu voyais en espèces de 2 contre
3 qui se dessine
tu vois au centre là pions rouge est bon
on peut imaginer que les noirs et ils
essayent de pousser fortement au centre
et tu vois les blancs ils essayent de
faire jouer leur espèce de il en effet
ce de quatre contre trois en fait tu
vois pas ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils ont
capturé en compte trois mais ce pion
dessin qui sert pas vraiment à faire de
rupture du coup c'est pas si évident que
ça des poussées sont leurs impôts
plus de développer de blanc comme les
autres par un petit peu plus le terrain
ils ont plus d espace mais les noirs ils
ont ce duo pion qui peut arriver mais du
coup s'il peut faire perdre tu as et que
si on pousse prend prend peut-être qu'il
peut ramener sa tour après comme ça bon
pour le moment je sais pas trop quoi
dire alexis pour le moment ça se
développe
je pense à peu près égales cette
position je pense pas que l'un des deux
joueurs soient vraiment mieux il ya plus
beaucoup de pièces sur l'échiquier
d'ailleurs plus de terrain pour le genre
j'aurai les blancs moi je me très bons
cavaliers en ont eu 4 à la rigueur
j'aimerais proposer l'échangé comme ça
tu fait avoir c'est un pur en même temps
ça me permet d'avancer le pion qui
arrange et 4 encore d'une 15 mai pour
venir leurs excès peut-être qu'ils le
préparent mais je pense si tu viens e4
il va prendre de toute façon moi mais
comme ça au moins ton pions en f3 il
arrivant en quatre ans
enfin wayne le 4 way c'est une
possibilité mais je pense ça permettrait
de protéger les autres qui sont que tous
les trois contre quatre
je pense que s'il n'a pas fait ça c'est
parce qu'il avait peur de se retrouver
avec tous les pions sur blanc tu vois il
aurait eu beaucoup de plans sur casse
blanche et avec le fou de cases blanches
qui aurait pu faire double emploi
ouais du coup ça peut être une idée
parfois mais peut-être s'il n'avait pas
eu le fou de cases blanches mais à une
autre pièce mineurs tu vois c'est quand
même un problème quand as tu vois et si
tu compte le nombre de pions là sur
blanc et on a quand même beaucoup pour
les blancs
du coup ce fou bah il n'est pas
forcément méga utile
vraiment on m'a toujours dit qu'en fin
de partie des fous sont plus petites que
les cavaliers mode c'est vrai parce que
justement le terrain est plus dégagé en
valeur c'est tout à fait vrai les fous
sont plus forts que les cavaliers en fin
de partie sauf si les pions sont sur la
même couleur que ton fou face y en a
beaucoup et là c'est le cas qu'ils ont à
l'oeuf où ils se calment un peu à
l'europe tout exprès en fait son
adversaire à hilla ville et le avec les
noirs tu veux dire ouais a clairement
oui
il est très content qu'ils gardent sont
fous l'aï joué 4 c'est un coup assez
typique
ce qui veut faire tu vois c'est quand on
va faire pu comprendre je pense que ça
va arriver donc je vais pas le mettre à
l'écran où fut prendront ils échangent
le fou du coup soit il va faire tout
recettes pour clouer soit il va prendre
on va voir ah ouais là il peut tellement
là avec sa tour il peut clouer ouais il
peut faire tout recettes pour venir
cloud et direct après comme ça le fou
peut plus bouger là du tout
et après on le ramasse ouais pas mal du
tout même
bah ouais parce qu'en plus il mais ça
faut enfin sa tour en recettes
il a deux cavaliers qui peuvent attaquer
la case au katla donc à la fin ils
craignent une pièce arrive à gagner
enfin il va gagner un pion et à faire
cavalier prend qui on prend tout reprend
et après il va re menacé en plus le pion
g4 et le pion c4 ouais bah ouais ça la
bonne affaire là voilà mon avis est
content surtout que si l'autisme à
protéger tural fou on peut encore en
remettre une couche
ah ouais c'est ce qu'il fait c'est pour
espacer là tu as le choix entre faire ça
vous faire cavalier prend ici et essayer
d'aller gratter salah c'était l'autre
option je pense qu'il va reprendre du
cavalier en fait vous ne passez au tour
sur la deuxième rangée bon pas pour le
moment il valait la fin c'est un ordre
de coûts en fait ça revient au même
c'est juste qu'il a joué dans un ordre
différent mais au final ce cavalier là
maintenant on va la récupérer
il est mort et tu vois le problème de
wesley ici c'est que ses pions là ils
vont tout de suite se faire attaquer par
la tour qui va tout de suite venir s'en
prendre aux pions c'est ça le truc mal
boel
ouais il est mal
il est mal barré il est mal barré je
vais juste vérifier ce que les que les
gens voient bien voit bien le live en
fait je sais pas si les gens si les gens
quoi quoi ça se plaint dans l'autre choc
fut pas un mec qui écrit à rien c'est
normal et l'autre s'est départi l
aveugle mais du coup je sais pas si
c'est de l'humour ou si la personne qui
voit rien mais
attends je vais regarder d'un point de
vue spectateurs ce que ça donne mais je
pense qu'ils le voient les ballons on
voit tout bien si la qualité pu tout
fonctionne bien tout fonctionne bien on
va poursuivre cette partie donc qu'est
ce qui se passe ici les noirs tu vois
ils ont deux pions passé ici donc qui
n'ont plus de deux vis-à-vis mais les
blancs ont réussi à s'en procurer un
aussi ils vont peut-être réussir à
choper le pion f6 de leur côté pour
égaliser complètement la position bon je
pense que ça va se solder par une nulle
cette partie mais les blancs doivent
être un petit peu prudent encore avec
deux tours tu savais nouvelle nul comme
je pense que tu vois il ya deux mots
enfin il ya toujours une balance
matériel qui égale
tu vois et au final il ya de moins en
moins de pièces et si du coup par
exemple le roi vent f2 et qu'on va
s'emparer du pion à 3 les blancs ils
peuvent faire un échec perpétuelle en
suivant le roi avec la tour ici tu vois
où cahill le roi sur ce petit carré de
bitume
tu vois la tour val va le mettre en
échec en fait c'est ce qu'on a construit
comme ça ça fait un nul au job quoi ce
qu'on appelle un échec perpétuelle en
fait ça ça va faire nulle part
répétition le coup en fait là ils
répètent la même position
donc il ya un joueur qui cliquent sur
nul et le et le site le site fait nul
direct donc ok match nul pour mise en
jambes
ok donc ici c'est une position ce qu'on
appelle un grand vide à l'idée du gambit
dames c'est que si le pion venait
s'emparer du pion c4 on voulait mettre
le pion le 4 on va on va attendre la
prochaine par touches de montreuil
du coup ça laisse un peu je veux te dis
ouais je vais rapidement les ouvertures
donc là les blancs tu as ils ont obtenu
une espèce de pioncer 5,7 théorique tout
ça c'est tout ça c'est encore la théorie
il on utilise ce pion ans et 5 tu vois
qui leur confère un avantage de terrain
comme tu nies davantage l'espace ma
pointois comme tu disais tu en a qui
préfèrent être en bien en gros bloc
comme tu veux avant toi même tu vas un
tut en fait allé noir donc tu acceptes
donner de donner un peu d espaces comme
ça le saf et utilise ça fait perdre du
temps à dire ça depuis ce qui doit jouer
des couples en l'espace mais comme ça
toi avec les noirs t'organises bien tes
pièces et tu dis que finalement tu vois
tes sur trois rangées mais bon enfin où
est le problème en réalité tu vois tes
pièces sont pas si mal placé
c'est un légèrement désagréable mais
c'est pas c'est pas gravissime
là nous quand même noter que ce foin f4
il est très fort parce que tu vois il
contrôle des casques quand même
importante éventuellement pour les
pièces noir tu vois ça leur salle est
rétrécie quelque part tu a rétréci le
jeu noirs souffrent f4 c'est pour ça
qu'il vient de faire food et 8 pour
venir le contester en fait d'accord ok
alors elle de bien bloquer son poulain
pour ça qu'ils veulent eux c'est pour ça
qu'ils veulent eux le met ici pour pour
venir le chat c'est celui-là et là il ya
quand même un thème important qu'il faut
voir c'est que à ce x 6 donc ce mec là
il tape sur une diagonale qui est
complètement vide tu vas y à rien dessus
c'est bien pour lui
du coup d'un côté c'est bien parce qu'il
a de l'espace d'un autre côté les blancs
ce qu'ils essayent de faire c'est de
rendre toutes ces cases là qu'ils
contrôlent en fait pas vraiment utile
pour eux comme ça ils espèrent que l'
influence du fou du fait que ces 15 là
on va pas s'en servir tu vois comme on a
beaucoup d espace en fait on a plus de
place pour nos pièces donc comme on a
plus de place pour nos pièces on peut se
dire que les kick ass que contrôle se
fout la voix est peut-être moins
importante tu vas le truc ouais donc
même si contrôle des cases bombe à kom
kom kom on a énormément de cases pour
nos pièces au final ça change carrément
sa stratégie est donc le fait de se dire
je mettrais pomme le pièce sur les cases
blanches
oui bah il s'organise en fonction de ça
en fait tu vois ce fou là il a un petit
peu bloquée entre guillemets parce qu'il
peut pas vraiment sortir de cette
diagonale il un peu bloqué là ils
contrôlent les cases mais tu vois toutes
ces cases là ils sont protégés par les
blancs en fait donc le fou il est bloqué
sur cette diagonale là et à très long
terme s'ils ont réussi à le bloquer
comme ça et qu'on le rend complètement
inutile
ça fera peut-être une pièce qui tapera
complètement dans le vide et peut-être
que nous avec les blancs du coup il nous
restera une pièce plus utile que la
sienne et qu'en bout de course on
gagnera ça peut être des idées comme ça
tu vois je vois bal al gore elle peut
mettre son fou en sus il peut revenir en
a 6 mai 2 à 6 du coup ci retourne ce
faire ces diagonales à toi de ce côté-là
de l'échiquier il se retrouve bloqué par
ses pions voilà bien un moment où les
plongeons bougeait pas il sait ce qu'il
espère oui en fait lui rêverait d'être
ici en fait voici ici pouvait faire un
coup de trafalgar
il mettrait au f5 du coup là il serait
plutôt bien placés en fait
ah là ils attaquent s'en fout on devrait
il a attaqué le fou il a forcé à prendre
il a dédoublé ses pions tu es là et deux
pions se doublaient et du coup il a
retrouvé il retrouve une structure deux
pions correct avec les blancs et ya
toujours le problème de sous bon ok pas
forcément gravissime mais il ya de
bonnes de la colonne a aussi dont on n'a
pas parlé les blancs sont sur la seule
colonne ouverte de l'échiquier ouais
mais au moins il a déplacé son pion à
chis donc y aura pas couloir si jamais
si jamais il met sa vanne sur l'accord
sur la ligne 8
de toute façon quoique non il peut pas
parce qu il ya le fou il ya le fond qui
est tapie mais bon c'est pas pour le
moment bien protégé le problème des
blancs ici en réalité c'est que tous ces
mots qu'on a dit sonner très doux aux
oreilles d'aniche guéri mais le truc
c'est qu'il faut trouver un moyen de
progresser est ici pour progresser avec
les blancs bah c'est pas évident parce
que tu voyais un peu de matériel pour
travailler entre guillemets donc ça me
fait encore une nulle ou quoi
normalement c'est bon à nice guy est
censé être le joueur le plus solide du
circuit c'est c'est un mec très très
très solide il perd très rarement et
wesley so comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il n'a pas perdu l'année
dernière pendant quelque chose comme 60
parties d'affilée donc ces deux joueurs
qui perdent très rarement
du coup dans ce match on pourrait voir
pas mal de nul mais c'est pas plus mal
alexis parce que qui dit nul 10 corser
dès qu'ils disent corse et ready
suspense dans la faim dans les bulles
est là quand ça joue une minute et du
coup on prend ceinture et il a mis sa
dann dans quelque part le rayonnement du
roi mais bon c'est pas pour nous il n'y
a pas de menace mais pas ok toutes les
pièces s'échange regarde je vais
échanger les dames maintenant
tu en es dans le chat pour moi cramique
est encore plus solide que guiry c'est
un mur en béton armé le truc je vais du
coup un débat sur qui est le plus solide
mais en tout cas il fait partie des
joueurs les plus les plus solides
quel intérêt ils auraient à échanger le
dom avec les noirs ouais en fait il veut
échanger le maximum de pièces pour qui
est fait pour qui reste presque plus
rien sur l'échiquier du coup hills enfin
ce sera assez pour faire nul du coup et
donc ils cherchent un nul il cherche la
nuit devrait hausser les deux chercheurs
nul celui avec les blancs il a quand
même le fou tu vois qu'il peut attaquer
les pions ah oui on ne fait ni un pion
pas protéger là bas le roi va venir
courir au secours du pion n'ya presque
plus de matériel sur l'échiquier le
fameux roi qui bouge en fin de partie
toujours un qui se met au centre cette
bataille de piolenc grand chose il n'y a
pas assez de points faibles chez l'un ou
l'autre des joueurs parfois ce qui peut
arriver là c'est marrant c'est que c'est
celui qui essaye de gagner dans ce genre
de partie qui peut se retrouver à perdre
en fait en voulant trop en faire on ne
tente rose offensif
oui voulant trop forcer la les blancs il
ils ont plus envie de forcer parce que
tu as tous les pions sont sur noir donc
il se dit tout et pions ils peuvent pas
être attaqué par le foot tu vois c'est
ce dont on a parlé du tout à l'heure en
fait c'est que se vouent là il peut se
balader sur l'échiquier mai
hilaire un peu comme une âme en peine
rien du coup il veut l'échanger mais
d'un autre côté les blancs avec leurs
fous ils peuvent attaquer que le pion
aux 6 et le plus réussi s'est défendue
par le roi à moins de prendre des
risques avec les blancs pour essayer de
forcer le gain est essayé de forcer la
porte en poussant un pion ou en faisant
quelque chose sinon normalement on peut
rien faire voici les changes la
lecavalier en ce2 il fait échec aux
rôles il menacera options des quatre
passages je vais mais je pense qu'il va
juste bouger le fou en fait par exemple
fou
quelque part c'est le mets en a quatre
ils menacent nas le pion gay pas
protégés en ce 6 ouais mais de toute
façon le roi pourra venir à tous les
cavaliers à deux c'est pas mal joué face
qui essaye de faire c'est pas mal c'est
que si tu prends le cavalier prend le
fou si tu prends le fouillis prendre
cavaliers et c'est assez malin là ce qui
va ce qu'il vient de faire parce que bon
je pense qu'il peut juste prendre le
cavalier en fait perso tiens là il ya un
choix intéressant à faire pour sauver ce
que tu gardes ton cavaillon ou est-ce
que tu gardes ton fou bon alors il faut
garder le cavalier vu comment les pions
sont sont 1000 ça paraît plus logique
je comprends toujours pas comment
guy peut gagner pour le moment mais bon
peut-être que en ayant échangé ces
pièces là on va réussir à se battre du
coup ils essayent de pousser tu vois ses
pions le maximum il prend de l'espace va
y avoir un moment où il faut savoir
confrontation quand même à l'ap si tu
veux essayer de jouer pour gagner tu
peux prendre avec le pion des tu vois et
tu créé un déséquilibre du coup tu
laisses un pion passé de ce côté là mais
tu obtiens un quatre contre trois de
l'autre côté si tu prends avec des et
c'est exactement ce dont je te parler
c'est que parfois quand tu commences
afin peut-être c'est bon et que tu
gagnes mais des fois quand tu es mieux
tu essayes de créer des déséquilibres et
ses déséquilibres là en fait ils peuvent
jouer en ta défaveur
donc là maintenant la position est moins
nul qui a quelques coups c'est plus
serré passait plus plus de chance pour
les deux joueurs mais du coup les blancs
prennent des risques ici clairement fait
ça va payer ça payera bat rennes lemay
enfants on va 4 finalement les protéger
pour le moment mais c'est à dire si
lecavalier bouge tu perds le pion du
coup peut-être qu'il veut faire f5 et
puis élargir le conflit bon alors c'est
3 avec le leroy jouable aussi ok du coup
en fait les noirs on décide rien faire
il bouge pas
attendre quoi passent leur tour de 10 m
moi je suis bien fait tapis dans l'ombre
je vais vérifier que le stream marche
bien je parais de presse m
réfléchi longtemps la fifa ce gars est
ce que tu respectes 30 secondes un état
du coup ça s'est passé comment tu es
parti sur czech gamme bah écoute ça va
j'ai l'impression d'avoir un petit peu
augmenté parce que là je tourne autour
des 910 donc qu'avant j'étais au 800m et
910 nuls mais là quand même
j'étais content de moi j'ai fait plein
de partis à 2 960 s'écoule par contre
c'est super dur de trouver des joueurs
en 960 allégeance à un peu conservateur
ils veulent pas trop jouer 960
malheureusement pourtant ses fans un est
justement toi veut qu'à pas de torts et
d'ouverture j'étais un petit peu plus
fort en option 60
je dois être les 305 5 mai à l'occasion
sûr on pourra se faire on pourra se
faire dès stream apprentissage si tu
veux il ya en anglais il ya des normes
est coach qui fait des choses comme ça
on va nous à des horizons fait nul
c'était sûr c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé à parler d'autre chose parce
que j'ai senti j'ai senti traquenard
mais après on pourra on pourra faire à
l'occasion et les mecs en anglais qui
font sourire ça sont les tees
entraînements du coup avec respect comme
il fait ça avec mes tu connais pas
frimeur qui s'appelle coach mais c'est
un stream harangue les deux gaming
je crois que c'est le seul streamer de
gaming dans les streamer connu un qui
fait qu'ils aient échec et il a réussi
maintenant ils et 1540 surtout s.com
d'accord donc c'est pas un vrai joueur
de chaque quoi non plus en plus il a
progressé au fil du temps puisqu'il a
fait beaucoup de stream et qu' il ya pas
mal de bahia daniel par exemple qui a
fait 1 qui a fait plusieurs stream avec
lui et il a fait pas mal de scream avec
des grands maîtres et les grands maîtres
il leur revient enfin il joue c'est
parti les grands maîtres commente en
direct c'est parti et puis après il est
recommandé en semblant fait pour essayer
de comprendre ce qui s'est mal passé
tout ça et pour le faire progresser
mais du coup là il bloque à 1500 il a
réussi à progresser jusqu'à mi 5550 si
je me rappelle bien et là il a ainsi un
petit passage à vide dont un palier à
passer après les biscuits l'hépatite va
manger quoi hobson pure et choco tu as
tu as raison de te nourrir ça va être la
mort faut que je mange parce que je peux
pas tenir losc à 22h33 manger 1
j'ai pas comment tu fais toi de moi va
j'ai mangé des petits trucs entre les
deux streams jets privés
j'ai pris des fruits secs moi je crains
pas de différend faisant mais de combien
87 ha ouais ouais tu me dire combien 33
mais je suis assez faim je suis pas j'ai
un vrai joueur d'échecs tu vois je suis
fan pourtant vous êtes constamment
justement pour ça tu as c'est mieux
d'être fin du coup pôle huile 87 65 et
tu manges combien de calories par jour
sas à finir en hausse - devrait on se
fait une petite émission top chef non
non je mange deux trois repas normal
tout à fait tu as tout à fait raison du
coup cette partie là bas position
toujours équilibré 1
là tu vois les colonnes qui se de
vierges la frontière kétou ouais il peut
y avoir une colonne qui se dégage et
ventes us et là le pion prend le 5 après
une bouche on s'en fout il a une bonne
colonne pour la tour le prg c'est pour
ça aussi qu'il vient de mettre sa tour
en baby tu vois le dernier coup il
prévoyait un petit peu tu vois en cas de
prises et reprises pour pour avoir les
une colonne aussi non
et pas mal du coup c'est l'avait prévu
mais a du coup ils poussaient pion au
centre assez intéressant dans le sens où
il faudrait faire quelque chose avec les
noirs tu vois il faut réagir puisque la
lecavalier est attaqué le fou est
attaqué par des gens là deux pièces
attaqué à west shawn heins le peut une
structure alors qu'il est un peu obligé
d'aller prendre le fou mais tu vois que
ça après l'obligé de prendre le faut et
après avec le plomb et reprend le lot de
plans le souci entre guillemets si tu
fais ça c'est que tu vois tous ses pions
sur blanc la autour du roi
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que si on
perd le flou de cases noires on va se
retrouver avec énormément de trous pour
les pièces blanches en fait c'est un peu
dangereux c'est pour ça qu'il a fait
cavalier 5
du coup il couvre le fou tu vois et il
somme le cavalier que protégé par la
reine mais c'est d'ailleurs là ces
bouchons sont fous et qu'ils avancent
son pion dangereux pour la reine
parce qu'il est protégé par la tour
après le pont alors tu veux bouger se
fout ici et jouer éventuellement des six
après pour menacer la reine
ça peut être une menace ou est du coup
si on fait fouet deux avec les noirs il
va falloir tout de suite réagir à ça ça
fait un pion qui est vachement près
baril vers la non enfin d'hommes pardon
possible il peut même peut-être essayé
de pousser d'abord et après enlever le
fou avec la même idée peut-être à ce à
quoi il réfléchit d'ailleurs de pousser
les pions direct ça peut être un truc
ça peut être un truc de pousser depuis
on dirait que ça peut être un truc
du coup pas une tête à des bonnes idées
tu sens bien le jeu il sent bien le jeu
des 6es cette idée de pousser les pions
mon avis c'est quelque chose que moi
c'est en train de bafouer 2 du coup à
[Musique]
aurais-je fait le même coup qu'un grand
maître international avec la mène